isn't life in America great but maybe
I'm just an out-of-touch rich guy wonder
what it's like for the middle class in
America what's left of our middle class
maybe on the verge of collapse the
American Dream is under siege corporate
America posting record profits so why in
the world or middle-class Americans
suffering from declining pay and
standards of living well that's a good
question Lou we headed to California's
Castaic Lake to confront some fat cats
as they played around in the water with
hardly a care in the world nothing but
fast toys Hummers and Escalades of
course their owners were happy to brag
about them ever seen the price tag for a
27-foot
boat it cost $50 it's a special bullet
for wakeboard at that wave ever believe
that this day is gonna be better than
yesterday
yeah well today is gonna be better than
yesterday if all you got to do today is
go wakeboarding this rich guy sees the
world through rose-colored designer
glasses probably a trust fund kid it
doesn't even have a job what do you do
for a living
I'm a gardener a gardener well well this
guy's got to be a fat cat CEO what's
your job so you must be like that
corporate CEO or something right before
something like this a cop for the big
boat in a Hummer aha
here's an auto mechanic who must be
struggling he's got no the boat belongs
to his buddy
a truck driver how can guys with regular
jobs afford all this
maybe we just happened to visit the lake
during a lottery winners reunion well
that is that is America's middle class
today it's amazing the amount of stuff
they're able to own and the consumption
levels that they are achieve today
compared to the past economist Michael
Cox is co-author of myths of rich and
poor why we're better off than we think
he says the middle class is doing great
but that's not what we hear on TV the
problem is their wages are low reeling
from stagnant wages so many things wrong
with that first of all those wages don't
include the benefits that we bargain for
would even if you add in benefits how
much you earn is only part of the story
how much things cost now that's another
important part it's the cost of
everything going down no is the cost of
the vast vast array of things that
Americans purchase going down absolutely
what that's not what other people say
it's dangerous it's a vicious vicious
cycle everything's going up money is how
we usually measure the cost of living
but Cox thinks we should use something
more important to us our time really the
best way to measure cost is in terms of
work time how long do I have to work in
order for to buy something so let's just
take a product for example a cell phone
the classic 80s movie Wall Street takes
us back to the early days of the cell
phone when corporate big shots went
cordless with their $4,200 bricks
my wife tells me you made a move on
Darien's
few regular people could afford
cellphones because the average worker
had a sweat for 460 hours to buy one boy
how times have changed
so there's $50 phone it's less than
three hours of work 460 then three now
he declines in prices enabling these
things to be afforded by the middle
class and many other products too only
the rich own cars a century ago but
today
average Americans can afford shiny SUVs
in terms of time the cost of a car is
fallen by more than 70% the story's the
same for necessities food is 84 percent
cheaper clothing is 87 percent cheaper
so foods going down clothing is going
down housing is going down and cost we
look at the houses and we see that
they're much more expensive than money
terms but the houses are also two and a
half times as large as back then and
they have all these amenities today the
typical new home comes equipped with a
dishwasher stove microwave fireplace
central heating air and a bunch of other
amenities that weren't standard in homes
50 years ago let alone a century ago the
falling cost of living allows to own
boats vacation at lakes and fly around
the world check it out
the cost of a cross-country flight has
plummeted by 95% when the flights first
came out they were exclusive purvey of
the rich the jet set but now the jet set
includes just you get on planes and look
there's people there of all income
levels such progress and yet so many
middle-class Americans feel lousy and
only 19 percent of middle-class
Americans feel they are getting ahead in
life gee I wonder why maybe they'd be in
a better mood if news programs weren't
packed with doom and gloom but you see
bad news gets raised remember the auto
mechanic who collects motorcycles works
good
even folks who say things are going well
for them are often convinced times are
tough for everyone else there's two big
guys and then there's the poor people
and there's anyway these are things that
they hear about propagated in the media
always get squeezed sir seems like he's
been watching a lot of TV squeezed is
what a lot of little class Americans are
these days the middle-class squeeze
there is a squeeze
if middle-class folks aren't getting
squeezed they're told they're victims of
war corporate America escalating its war
against the middle class and it's always
more difficult to make ends meet
make ends meet it's very very difficult
to make ends meet but if you're willing
to settle for living standard of the
1970 it's easy to make ends meet it's
not the high cost of living it's the
cost of living high it's the fact that
we insist on having so much more to bed
putting things in perspective is rarely
considered newsworthy but today much of
the American middle class is struggling
it's much easier to stir up anxiety the
Iraq war may be democratic voters top
issue but economic anxiety comes next
and bad news doesn't just get ratings it
also gets votes while productivity and
corporate profits are up the fruits of
that success just hasn't reached many of
our families it's like trickle-down
economics but without the trickle your
life is bad it's clearly cruel and
unfair vote for me and I'll help it's a
bipartisan theme our dynamic economy is
leaving working people behind there are
people suffering out there and they've
always been people suffering out there
there will always be people suffering
out there the poor you will always have
with you but how does it compare to the
past
Americans are richer today that at any
time in history we should really be
thankful that we live in a society where
we don't have to work day and night in
order just to beat out a living we could
spend more time with family and friends
because it takes less time for us to buy
the things we need so if you look at it
that way the future will be even better
than today so don't worry you'll still
be able to tell your kids how tough you
had a compare to them for reason TV I'm
drew Carey